with important information.
Information that cannot be
rejected. Information that
cannot be ignored. Then seek
evidence to bolster or reject
this news that he has brought
to you.
Here Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says, oh you have believed. If
they fast, if they fast, if
a in Islamic legislation is
considered someone who has not
repented from major sin.
Someone who has not repented
from major sin. When I say
repented, meaning that this
person used to do something but
they have changed their ways.
This is repenting or this
person got caught doing
something and they were
punished for it. They're now
considered innocent, right? In
the Arabic language, this word
comes from the root word which
is was seen. In this order,
this a nation of letters,
articulates something emerging
and something falling away
after being after being on
something. So, for instance,
the Arabs usually use this word
to articulate when someone
peels the skin off of a fruit,
let's say an orange. They will
describe this act here as
Fasakah. Or when a fruit grows
and it sheds its outer skin
end. This is referred to from
the same root word as and so,
it's somebody in the Islamic
law. It's someone who is upon
Islam and then, their Islam
erodes by committing a major
sin that they have not repented
from. This person is considered
a there are certain things in
the Quran, certain things in
the Sunnah. If you do them even
one time, the person who does
this is a for instance,
insulting another Muslim.
Insulting a Muslim is Fusook.
The prophet said that.
Insulting a Muslim is Muslim is
So, doing that even once is
considered the person who does
this a festival. But it may be
other things that a person
becomes a due to major sins
that they have not repented
from etcetera. The point here
is that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says oh you have
believed. If a comes to you,
with an undeniable piece of
information Now, he uses the
word Nebah. Nebe and Chabar in
the Arabic language, same word
except that a Neba is only in
really important things. We
call it a this is a piece of
news. We that is really
important. It's not just
information. It is a Neba.
Alright? This Neba means that
this person who is a brings to
us something that he says he
saw, something that he said he
heard. Something that is going
on. Something that happened.
But it's not just anything,
it's a never. it's something
that we can't just brush aside.
We have to look into it because
it's important It's a matter of
it's a matter of safety. It's a
matter of something that we
need to find an answer, a
conclusion to. Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala says that
seek to validate this
information or invalidate it.
How do we do that? Maybe with
another person's testimony and
we're sure that these two
people have not met each other.
Or maybe by going to the scene
to see whatever it is or
verifying. So we are to verify.
We're not to just accept out of
the blue. We look at this
person. This person is someone
who could lie. Maybe isn't. So,
we have to verify now. Notice
the wording, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says, meaning that if it
is a is opposite of in Islamic
law. If it's a someone we know
to be a good person upon Islam,
We know nothing of lying from
this person. We don't know that
they are ever been dishonest
with us. We don't know any
anything bad about the person
but Hiro they tell us
something, we accept it. The
essence, the the norm is that
god-fearing person does not
lie. The norm is that he could
lie but he doesn't. That's the
exception. Right? And the norm
is that a person who is a lies.
Not saying everything he says
is a lie. We're saying, the
norm is that he lies. It's not
a big deal to them. If it's not
a big deal for this person to
do something that is a major
sin. A little lie or a little
embellishment isn't going to be
a big issue for that kind of
person. It's not someone We
know them as someone who
doesn't watch what they say.
They don't measure their words.
And so, Allah tells us to
verify. And so verification may
be in a number of ways.
However, even if it comes out
to be correct and true, the
principle is, is that we accept
the information but we may not
accept the opinion There's a
difference between someone's
opinion, someone's analysis,
and someone's testimony. We
don't want them to give us an
opinion. We want them to give
us a testimony. This is what I
saw. This is what I heard. This
is what I know. That's it. Not
to tell us. This is what my
opinion is or this is what we
should think about it or this
is a conclusion that we should
come to or this is what we
should do as a reaction because
that has its people Formulating
opinions, everyone has them,
and most of them are not very
useful.
We'll continue tomorrow
inshallah.